cut off from the world for used under
strict Israeli military control people
in Gaza are used to being isolated and
their movements restricted
self-quarantine many say won't be too
difficult if there's a corona virus
outbreak more than 11 years of blockade
by land sea and sky
we have no tourists to bring the virus
here maybe something good came from the
bad the Gaza Strip is reported to be
coronavirus free but the Health Ministry
isn't taking any chances encouraging
people to stay indoors and avoid crowds
Gaza is one of the most densely
populated places in the world adding to
fears that if the corona virus is
detected here it will spread quickly
border crossings with Israel and Egypt
are closed only emergency travel is
allowed Gaza hasn't registered any cases
thank God I'm here to leave Gaza for
four months
I need a liver transplant coronavirus or
not death is death the Health Ministry
and aid organizations are running
awareness campaigns to inform everyone
about how to stop the virus spreading
this corona virus arrives we will perish
I don't think the Health Ministry has
the capacity to deal with it because of
the Israeli siege the World Health
Organization warns that people in Gaza
are vulnerable there's a chronic lack of
hospitals basic medical supplies and
testing kits Gaza won't be able to deal
with the thousands or hundreds of cases
and at that stage we would need to think
of something or some response plan that
would allow either the transfer of some
cases the difficult cases or to open
resources or hospitals to deal with the
virus if it is in hundreds
precautionary measures have been stepped
up this week the interior ministry says
it will release prisoners who served two
thirds of their sentences to reduce the
chances of coronavirus spreading in
jails government buildings mosques and
shared spaces are being disinfected
Medina will try to cover all of the city
but our resources are limited
we need more efforts for this emergency
involving all of the local and
international health institutions our
schools shut down students are tuning in
to hear lessons on local radios
they're also listening out to keep up
with fast-moving developments just like
all causes two million residents crammed
into the narrow strip of land Sarah hi
dirt al Jazeera